what's up guys what's Sovereign back
again tax East 2023 I had the pleasure
of being joined by Sean Alexander Allen
developer of the game treachery and
Beatdown City Sean thank you for joining
us of course now you've finished all
your work on treachery and Beatdown City
and now you have these DLCs coming out
right can you talk about the game proper
for anybody who may not know about the
game and then the DLCs of course uh it's
a game uh it's a little hard to explain
sometimes uh
I like to call it a power fantasy for
the oppressed uh the game where your
three POC fighters who get to fight
uh like white supremacists uh fascist
cops all the bad things yeah like uh
just or just or just dudes that just are
really aggressive with their rap CDs
they won't give up on
and uh and and also ninjas now um but uh
so it's a game that's uh kind of we look
to look at as a subversion of beat em
ups like I really love beat em ups but
beat em ups are all about like
disposable characters absolutely and our
game like I'm from New York and you know
for New York uh biracial black kid my
mom was white so my hair is Big I'm
brown people like what are you who are
you are you this person's kid people are
really aggro in New York with Husky
about literally everything cops
everybody stop you what if you could
fight those people that was a big part
of my anxiety and I'm living in the city
also the bigger you get the more cops
one of them and that's what hugeover no
reason uh also then like over the course
of the last decade like with uh you know
all the black lives matter stuff and
like it's just matching up like just
getting more and more like I almost got
like I got stopped one day working on
this by two White Plain closed cops in
my neighborhood one block away from the
train I stepped off of in a button-down
shirt like walking slowly listen to my
music and they're like you fit a
description because of your hair and I'm
like yeah and my button-down shirt and
with my headphones and my backpack on
because I'm walking real slow for a
procedures around somebody with a knife
I actually snugged my way out of that
but I was like I was scared I was like
What if I was like shaking afterwards is
is this game sort of your way of sort of
kind of not lasting out but sort of
cathartic in a way exactly yeah let's
say that's why I say it's a power
fantasy for the oppressed it's like what
if we could fight the cops what if you
could fight all the people who get up in
your business and so it's got like I
love beat em ups uh but I really like
Double Dragon on the Nintendo because it
was like this I was an only child I
played it by myself it's like an RPG you
gain these uh experience yeah and you
could play it differently to learn
different things also similarly like in
college all my friends went away to
school I found fire for wrestling and I
found those forums and that became my
thing like I loved wrestling I loved
fire pro wrestling especially for the
Creation Suite right creation also the
whole the whole character that they
could actually have like realistic
wrestling fights because we can set the
behavior of characters that they start a
certain way and end a certain way in a
certain way yeah and then I love
fighting games but again I grew up
without being able to play with other
people all the time right and I love
RPGs like fancy and all that stuff again
so like we were like we first started
off like I'm a big fan of city base
games so like
like when Castle Crashers came out I was
like this is okay but like hey it
doesn't feel as good as like old Double
Dragon I need denting it's not in the
city right it's just like kind of
generic nights and I was like I don't
really like this that much and I like
started getting inspired to do indie
game stuff so I was like let's make a
beat em up let's make the best beat them
up and then we were working on it I was
like I don't really like all this
jamming on stuff because I don't know if
that's what's gonna be gone but I I went
to I had a shower moment I literally
went to the shower I was sad I was like
about to cry because I was like we're
gonna cancel this project no and then I
like fought and I was like well what
would like Fallout 3 like that and I was
like put like hybrid Heaven which is a
game that's like a turn-based exactly 3D
fighting game that my business partner
and I used to play together on N64 and I
was like super RPG I love this game and
I was just like we're gonna mix this
together all together so tell us
how that all comes together trying to
beat down City like talk about the game
no not at all but again I love the we're
from New York as well yeah so we we
understand where you're coming from in
terms of where you're getting the energy
to make this game and then all the games
you talked about we love and play as
well so the idea that you're gonna take
a game that's simplistic and look right
and say hey I'm gonna put everything
that I love about games into this one
product that's an amazing thing so talk
about it yeah so uh yeah so it's like
you uh we ended up like we wanted to
make these little kids they're more like
Arenas because you fight one on one to
three characters on One map right you a
lot of times there's an inciting moment
where there's a little cut scene where
the characters are just gruesomely drawn
like uh Ren and Stimpy to really kind of
show the like right it makes you want to
hate them they say something terrible to
you they're like they call you the help
they think you're homeless because
you're black like all sorts of stuff and
then you get to fight them you get the
snarky your characters are snarky they
get to snap on them but then you get to
stamp on them and then you build so the
whole thing is actually it was that
mechanic a back and forth for real like
is it something that you can engage with
in the cutscenes right I did I sent a
lot with a lot of I know a lot of
comedians because I hung out of the
County Section very well so that's
actually what helped me write comedy in
the first place like I always feel like
I got to take a cab with Hassan like
before he was like really big right just
because I was like hanging with
Comedians and he was like I'm going to
Manhattan I'm like I need to get to
Manhattan too okay just dropped me off
like I was with all these great
comedians that were like talking all
this like you know like comedians were
like under like so like that really
inspired me key and peel inspired me
since Mad TV even I've loved them for a
very long time get out all that stuff
really like coalesce in the writing okay
and then so it's like we call it a dark
comedy for that reason so when you get
in the fight it's like you kind of
remember that they look like it was a
weird person you remember all the things
they said to you even though they're
simple art the heart's all based on like
my love of Double Dragon on the Nintendo
which was like one of my favorite games
like I just called the style because it
feels like gritty New York absolutely
very specifically and that game also had
like black and brown characters in it if
you wouldn't mind would you could you
describe a little bit of the game class
going on here absolutely uh well he just
finished the tutorial of fighting uh
ugly John ugly John so you're getting
actually because these are uh these are
arenas you can go left or right okay
like this the scrolling implements are
the top down elements so we like we had
to figure out a way to put together the
fights and I was like well you know like
Mario Mario like three or whatever any
of those games so you got you got your
real-time attacks that you could use and
those are good for like open up objects
they're good for this is still like a
tutorial we're just teaching about what
happens when you get hit in the back
so for somebody who does it who's
looking at it right now they're looking
at it like this is a turn-based RPG yeah
it's like it's real time and turn base
yeah so it's like we say it's like we
like to see it's like Double Dragon
these bats and then where it's like you
can pause at any moment
so yeah now you're leaving the gym
because uh your dad's been trying to
call you because the president's been
kidnapped and he's trying to be like hey
I need your help
um I think it's kind of it's
revolutionary to be like you started a
game with like a dark-skinned Puerto
Rico woman and she gets to talk to her
puppy coming out of them that is exactly
it you can take hold of those sort of
norms and tropes that we sort of
recognize as the norm and kind of turn
them on their head right yeah so Sean we
saw this game honestly for the first
time this past January at the New York
game awards oh and Harold Goldberg
couldn't stop going crazy about it right
and we were so excited to see you go up
there and talk about the game uh tell
everybody when obviously trust me beat
down cities out already yeah when can
they get the DLC and the other and the
other facets of the game and yeah like
what platforms can they get it on yeah
so the DLC we're hoping there's a launch
so uh end of April okay
um yeah it's coming out DLC if anyone
has the game on switch or PC
um it's going to be a free update oh
amazing uh which is unwise but I but I
want to just make sure everyone has it
it's coming out on Xbox
also at the same time uh the whole
thing's going on Xbox it's now like
Ultra remix that's like the new title of
it oh we're being kind of a Mac Linux uh
it's just someone from Epic anybody like
yo you want help they don't have the
games
and we're
also working on a PlayStation version we
do not know if it'll be out right then
but it'll be out soon but that'll be
everything will be out very soon that's
great to hear this is like us trying to
like we launched this into the pandemic
after working on it very hard me and my
me and my my uh programmer who started
it with me he scaled up to like four or
five people but like we were both like
four kids from the hood like he was
working on this in the projects and he
would get asthma attacks because of the
mold in his house yeah and we would like
it would delay us for like a month
because he just couldn't work for a
while and it was like and like we
launched it into the pandemic I'm like
taking care of my kid during the day so
now we're like uh people believed in it
and they wanted to invest in us to allow
us to really put it out as best as
possible so that's what we're doing
right now we are so delighted to be able
to put a spotlight on the game like I
said we fell in love with it the mute
how quickly oh yeah the music let's talk
about the music and the influences so we
got um so the musician for the whole
game is this guy inverse phase he's out
in uh he used to be called Mr magfest
magfest is like the big uh Games music
festival uh he's like an amazing
shifting artist actually found if you're
going to cover of Cee Lo Green's forget
you or you uh like a chiptune
version so I heard that and I thought it
was funny I was like I want to work with
this guy and we've been working for a
long time on stuff we actually worked on
music for like something before this was
a game and I thought I'd just be the
insurance of the game and then um so
then I was like after years and years
years I started meeting rappers I met
like Mega ran and I opened my giggle I
meant open my Google like eight years
ago at the High Line uh in the Highline
Ballroom yeah Manhattan that's down
closed coast and uh he opened for Doom
free and I came over and it turned out
he liked video games and I fell in love
with his music and I was like I gotta
work with this guy
um and so uh yeah he was like I was like
yo you want to do like a song together
he was like hell yeah so then we worked
with him and this guy Matt uh uh two
Mello who does a lot of music for games
but he's also does a lot of rap albums
so and he does like jets that radio like
in future in those inspired elements I'm
in love with the music when we when we
heard it so like all three of that came
together we did that for the first game
and then we were like let's and then I
brought a around to do this we've
got a another remix dropping I'll just
try with another rapper and a whole new
beat okay coming out closer to release
so it's really it's funny if I told Mike
like like Teenage self like yo you're
gonna have like rappers that you
love like making this thing together in
the future and be like wow like I would
have believed you would have never
thought about it so like we said it's on
we fall in love with the game when we
saw it